[Musique]
une grande formation à l'image des
années 50-60 le hollywood orchestra vous
fait traverser l'atlantique à l'époque
des studios d'hollywood et des grandes
maisons de disques ou forme de démesure
ça c'est certain
c'est à dire que des mesures par là par
là l'importance du projet le nombre de
musiciens prouver le caractère marqué
strahl et puis
plus spécifiquement par rapport aux
arrangeur un goût du détail et de la
discrétion aussi qu'est vraiment
particulier c'est des arrangeurs
qu'écrit pour accompagner les chanteurs
des chanteuses la plupart du temps et
qui ont réussi à donner à la fois un
caractère important aux morceaux qui
écrivait tout en restant très discret un
rendre hommage aux arrangeur les
musiciens qui crée orchestre souvent
dans l'ombre pour l'occasion les
quatorze musiciens de l'homme note big
band se transforme pour être 39 sur
scène accompagné de chanteurs la musique
elle est vivante si ça du coup le même
nom à la mettre dans un contexte festif
c'est aussi je trouve la rhumerie
vivante et la faire sortir des musées là
pour le mur arkestra l'aspect festif il
est toujours là il est important pour
nous une des mesures à l'américaine qui
fait du jazz une fête lors qu'être
redevient l'homme laddh big band 7 mars
prochain à doué pour un hommage à
donnery mal
[Musique]